Mùi môi thống bởi trên trang mặt số gà nhắn,
tổng thống mì tôi năng trăm công bố thư bảo thời gửi
các nader thông bảo mức thời và me lâm phần trăm sẽ được áp giụ
với toàn bộ hàng hoàn sức khẩu, đường nữ này sống Mỹ,
bắt đầu từ ngày 1 tháng 8, ông kể bảo nếu các nader đáp trả
mức thời có thể tăng thêm.
Thuy gên các dành giật các nader sẽ xuất tại Mỹ sẽ được miệng thời gửi
với càm kết Mỹ sẽ giúp ngàn thuộc các phép chỉ trong vải tôn.
Cà nader là đối tắc thơ mạ lượng thứ 2 của Mỹ,
và là nước mùi nhiều hàng mi nhất quan hệ hai bên gần đây càng thẳng
gió cá đòn thế chả đủ lệ nhau, đặc biệt trong lĩnh vực nhóm
thép và dịch vụ số, mùa thật an ninh kịch tẻ tình được lên kể
hoàn tất trọng thẳng sấu, nhưng đã bị đình trẻ sau khi ông Trump dừng
đàn phán gió các nader áp thế đối với các hàng công nghệ Mỹ,
dù ở tờ qua đã giúp lại thế đàn phán hiện bệ trưa đường nơi lại.
Cung thầy em ông Trump cạnh bảo sẽ áp thế bộ xung mười phần chăm,
đối với tọn vụ hàng nhập khẩu, từ các cung ra thuộc nhóm rick,
bao gồm cả các thêm viên mời ghi kí ra, của ai ai và ai cập,
ông khẳng định bất kỳ của ra nào, ông hộ các chính xách trong mỹ của Brick
đều không được miệnh trường.
Nóng thái này nhằm đối phó bơi nỗ lực của Brick trong việc giảm phụ thuộc
vào đường đối là Mỹ, thuộc đợi tháng tuán măng đồng nỗ tẻ và xây dựng
hệ thống tại chính ghi dân thầy thế cho Swip.
Tổng thống Trump cho rằng thư quan sẽ vụ cửa nước Brick phải xem xét lại từ các thêm viên,
đồng thời đuân bố sẽ không cho phép bất kỳ rằng kên nào
làm xí yếu vai trọng tọn cầu của đồng đối là,
các nhà lãnh đạo Brick trong tiên bố chung tại ríu đối dân dân rộng và nghe chất,
cũng bệnh tiến phạt đối các bạn pháp thời đơn phương,
được hiểu là nhằm bỏ tríng xách thường mạc ứng dãng của Washington.